there are two hot movies currently
playing in your local theaters the stars
from both of them are with us tonight in
Spain he is known as el hombre los
Mozgov even or as the sexiest man alive
wait a second Nick Nolte aren't you the
sexiest man alive you are right and
Kevin Costner warns you the sexiest man
alive last year you know finished second
Jack Palance so you got him and she is
from the box office hit Basic Instinct
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Sharon Stone and the Mambo Kings Antonio
Banderas
in the movies if the actor opens a
bottle of wine and a scene the soundman
provides them but if you step on a cat
in the dark the cat provides that
greener sound effects editor' makes sure
that why that's in and got them we have
the enchanting assignment to present the
glamorous award for sound effects
editing backdraft gary rides Tim and
Richard hims Star Trek 6 the
undiscovered country
George waters the second and F Hudson
Miller Terminator 2 Judgment Day
Gary Rydstrom and Gloria as for ders and
Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes to Gary
Rydstrom and Gloria s quarters for
terminator 2 the day
thanks Academy members for this great
honor I share it with the most creative
hard-working effects and Foley team ever
thanks to my friends Kay Coombs Ron
Jacobs and Karin Harding and especially
to my mother and father for giving me
the strength and confidence and
inspiration to follow this dream we'd
like to thank Kuroko and twice star for
the opportunity this film was a
collaboration of a lot of talented
people starting with Jim Cameron we
truly share this award with everybody at
Skywalker Sound north their work and
their support their inspiration is what
keeps us going
I hold personal thanks to my family for
their enthusiasm all my friends for
keeping me laughing and Cindy for
everything thank you another former
Oscar winner returned mr. Denzel
Washington
the second film nominated for Best
Picture is a Camelot production from
Warner Brothers it is the bold retelling
of disturbing events leading up to and
following the assassination of John F
Kennedy arguably the most controversial
movie of the decade so far its power has
caused overwhelming audience reaction it
is of course JFK